we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
they're working on life below zero can
be very dangerous guns here cameras here
never know what to expect you see that
gonna be tough but we're gonna get the
shot every scenario we got to prepare
for this we're still smiling we're
having fun still making like below zero
yeah bring it on we are wrapping up our
episode with Jesse and he's just gonna
be clearing out some trees I think to
make it interesting we are gonna have a
quick GoPro time-lapse set up we are
just trying to figure out the best way
to cover because once you cover one or
two trees we want to show maybe a nice
little time-lapse of Jesse cutting trees
which we've seen a lot on life below
zero a lot of tree cuttings so it's kind
of unique to try to figure out maybe
just how to do it a little different
each time the idea of the time-lapse is
not to interrupt the flow it's a great
way to tell a story of someone clearing
a space I filmed probably five years of
people cutting down trees on life below
zero we're always trying to think of
just something different at some point
I'll put the drone up and we'll cut the
trees we'll put a GoPro on the saw we'll
do all that so this is just a different
way to just capture a different look to
it we're working outside all the time
and we covered a lot but variety is
important you kind of give it make it
more dynamic you know you can see
someone chain saw three million times
but the more we can do with different
angles different camera placement it's
getting creative and doing our best to
make it look different each episode so
he's gonna be able to reach up to hear
those branches maybe
if even if he cuts a little bit of this
bridge but what has that look there yeah
there you go nice that's good yeah oh
man let's gonna look cool sped up so now
we'll have like two different time
lapses of two sections of Boris because
we have a master shot and this will just
be a nice cut away when it's sped up
watching it cleared out and be able to
cut to this magnificent view what I did
is we just got a high and wide attached
the GoPro onto a branch up here that we
anticipate jesse is going to cut down a
couple other branches to clean off
so we'll get like a little reveal with
these branches the beauty of this is
that we have another GoPro in the back
we have two time lapses that the editors
can choose and pick from it's gonna be
tough but we're gonna get the shot
little extra effort goes a long way it
definitely takes a certain breed to film
up here half the battle is the ingenuity
and being innovative and creative
[Music]
filming with Jesse Holmes out here on
his new piece of land just trying to do
a simple little move with the drone I'm
trying to fly it back in here and then
do a nice move in through the trees but
this alder II stuff got in my way the
typical thing of trying to fly a drone
in the trees and looking at the screen
and not knowing exactly where your drone
my beat yeah one broken crop most
valuable thing in this whole drone is
the gimbal the gimbal it's very fragile
but that's fine there we go big integral
part of our show right there gives a
whole different element to the to the
shot to the angle showing Jesse walk
around it's one thing which shown an
aerial shot or shoveling snow in a in a
cool location you're trying to showcase
Alaska and how beautiful it is and this
is a key part to to showing all that so
fix is no big deal drone itself is going
to be completely operable
and it's like today no big deal we're
good to go
you never know what to expect out here
from changing weather to equipment
failure we have to be ready for anything
so we're gonna go out and find a game
can that I've set up a couple days ago
we're shooting a ratty daring story with
Jesse but it is really important it
gives us a look into the life of the
animal that we're about to catch because
you know usually when we're shooting we
don't see these animals we see it once
we've caught it so to see it in this
natural environment one of the most
intimate ways you can interact with an
animal and get the shot at the same time
it gives us another layer in any hunting
story whether it's caribou moose bear
whatever to get these shots gives us
that and other look into that animals
life
just by snowmobiling up here you can
tell there's a lot of fresh snow a lot
of new snow from last night about three
inches all right so we've made it to one
of the first spot the new snow is
definitely gonna make it a little more
of a challenge to find the skin cam a
little worried that the lens is covered
so I'm just have to start searching and
see so when I set the game cam up
originally it was uncovered but kind of
hidden at the same time so animals can
look there's been a lot of recent wind
loading which means the wind is been
pushing the snow into new areas and on
top of that it snowed about three and a
half inches the other night so I'm kind
of thinking the cameras gonna be buried
so we have to do some digging
unfortunately all the former rabbit
tracks are covered up nothing's going
through here so that kind of makes me
think we might not see something or that
the whole cameras covered up the wind
would have triggered the center of the
camera so we could have a lot of shots
of just snow falling and no rabbits so
I'm hoping that the lens is uncovered
and that we have at least a couple shots
with some rabbit I might have just a
little bit it's in this area I'm gonna
start looking because if we can't see it
already
oh yeah that can all cover that is too
maybe next time market glad we found
this I get to keep my job now it's
pretty lucky
[Music]